kirkpatrick sale where did you get then
title for your book the fire of his
genius
well Robert Fulton when he died at an
early age was compared to the self
consuming tree of Gambia I don't know if
any such tree exists but that's what was
said at his funeral and that the fire of
his genius ate him up like the self
consuming tree of Gambia and I think
that's the key to Fulton his character
that fire for fame and riches that's why
I called the subtitle Robert Fulton and
the American dream because it was that
American dream of Fame and riches which
he acknowledged right from the beginning
he wanted he didn't make any bones about
that's what he was out for and he would
do anything to get there and he got it
but the process ate him up and that's
the the larger theme of Robert Fulton
and the American Dream is that getting
the American Dream is one thing but in
the process we tend to eat ourselves up
and we tend to have effects the rest of
the world that we don't even pay any
attention to there are costs in the
American dream where did you get the
idea to do a biography on Robert Fulton
well I live alongside the Hudson River
and so I've been wanting to write about
the Hudson for some time but what
happened was that I wanted to write a
book about computers and what was wrong
with computers and the effects that
computers are gonna have on our lives
that we have no idea about because
technology always has ripple effects
that go on and on for decades and
centuries even that are unintended and
unknown but I couldn't get anybody to
take a book was questioning computers as
hard as I wanted to so I said let me
find another technology back where it's
not so emotive and talk about that and
what effects they did have and so
naturally I thought about the steamboat
and the steamboats that it was first
used successfully on
River so that led me back to Fulton and
the steamboat and I saw that the
steamboat was in fact the industrial
revolution brought to America in England
they have steam factories as their
industrial revolution but here we had
water powered factories we didn't need
steam factories but we had steam boat
and that brought the Industrial
Revolution to America and so the book
became although I hadn't intended a kind
of companion piece to a previous book I
had written about the Industrial
Revolution in England and the Luddites
who resisted it in England and failed
and the Industrial Revolution happened
so this is the Industrial Revolution in
America and what were the consequences
of that technology that was that was my
goal while I was also writing about all
the intimacy's of his life and they are
quite bizarre indeed but but the larger
goal was to talk about the effect of
this technology on America when did
Robert Fulton live he lived he he lived
1760 to 1815 and he created his
steamboat in 18-7 so he had just a few
years eight years of fame and fortune
but but he loved those eight years but
he spent so much time worrying about his
fame and going to courts going to
legislatures trying to protect his
patent and the monopoly that he had on
the Hudson River
that that ate him up that was the fire
that consumed him far too early he died
much too early in his career and had
only eight years to to carry out the
steamboat legacy you say you live on the
Hudson River
we're in Cold Spring New York it's about
260 miles north of Manhattan what's
special about the Hudson River oh my god
it's the most beautiful River in America
that's the first thing and it's flat now
you don't know about flat rivers
it is flat from New York to Albany and
that's the extraordinary thing about it
it's it's like a Scottish law in that
sense and it's not it's like a lake and
then there are these mountains that go
up on either side of it
and there are turns and twists it's a
beautiful link of the beautiful river
but because of that beauty it was a
river that needed the steamboat the
story here is interesting because the
very first successful steamboat was done
on the Delaware River from Philadelphia
to Trenton now that should have been a
marvelous success except that in that
river it was it was there there no
twists and turns to it there are no
difficult currents and so sailing boats
went up and down without any trouble and
the banks of the Delaware there are easy
for stagecoaches to go on so the guy who
built his steamboat didn't have any
customers because nobody needed to go on
a frightening kind of a loud and ugly
steamboat because they could go by a
sail or by carriage but on the Hudson
you couldn't do that it was a long and
arduous coach journey to go from New
York to to Albany because of these
mountains in the way and because the
Hudson twists and then the currents are
so treacherous it was difficult for
sailboats that's why the steamboat was
necessary for the Hudson River as it was
necessary for the Mississippi and and
the other rivers of America where was
Robert Fulton originally from he came
from Lancaster Pennsylvania and the
interesting thing about that is that
there was a war going on the
Revolutionary War going on at that time
and Lancaster was the headquarters for
much of the army and for prisoners of
war and it was a major center of gun
manufacturing so that full-t grew up
with all of this material military
further going on about him and it went
into his soul it struck his stole soul
very deeply so that when he began his
inventive career he turned almost
immediately after a few dodges here and
there almost immediately to weapons of
war and he invented a submarine and he
invented what he called torpedoes which
were in fact land mines but he he
created these and he and he proved that
they could work he went down in the
submarine came back up he created this
in France and he tried to sell it to the
French government which was at war with
England at the time and he was trying to
persuade Napoleon this is the great
thing to blow up the ships of England
and Napoleon thought about it and then
he said well let me see it and Fulton
wouldn't let him see it
Fulton said I destroyed it because he
didn't want them to copy it without him
getting the fame and fortunes from it so
Napoleon said no I'm not interested and
Fulton went over to England and he said
to the same thing to the English our
billet for you to destroy the French
fleet and the English were interested
for a while now the interesting thing
here is that there's another country
involved which is Fulton's own country
the United States and this was an act of
treason to provide a weapon of war which
would be used against the United States
as well as against the France or England
but it didn't bother him he didn't
consider it treasonous because again
this drive for wealth and fame was was
eating and propelling him but were his
parents like it's hard to know the
difficulty in writing a biography of
someone who gets to be famous only later
in life is that all that early history
is pretty much forgotten
and it's there there's just a shadowy
record there his farm his father however
was a failure that's that seems clear he
tried to establish a farm and that
failed he was a kind of a itinerant
salesman in Lancaster and without much
success
and it seems clear that that was one of
the motives for Fulton in his in his
drive to be a success
what about smother know practically
nothing about her he wrote a few letters
to her but if she wrote to him
those letters don't survive she's an
anonymous figure how much schooling did
he have again that's uncertain but
probably six to eight years something
like that before he then went off to
Philadelphia to apprentice to a jeweler
and apparently made hair locket with
pictures in lockets the people wore and
then he became a miniature painter and
set himself up in a studio in
Philadelphia and then that lasted for
only a couple of years before somebody
gave him the money to go to England to
become a real painter how old would he
abandon when he was in Philadelphia
during the painting that's his late
teens have you seen anything that he
actually drew or any to locket something
like that well yes there are a couple of
extant miniatures that he did which are
not bad not distinguished and and don't
look as if they would propel someone to
give him the money to go to England to
become a real painter although that's
clearly what happens but we again the
record is so sketchy that we know very
very little about it when he does get to
England starts painting well though we
can see the same kind of thing adequate
paintings
the ones that survived but nothing
distinguished nothing nothing nothing
great about him and he spent five or six
years as trying to be a painter and
failing
in England and you can see that he
somehow it didn't put his fire into that
that wasn't what what what what he
thought was gonna get him his fame and
fortune so what year would he have been
in England 1790 1798 and at the end of
that he decided that he would be an
inventor or an engineer as he called
himself and he went around trying to
invent this and that the other he had
played with the idea of a steam boat
even even as early as 1793 had a steam
boat been invented in those in 93 in a
sense in the sense it had been invented
because there was a man named John Fitch
in Philadelphia who had invented a
working steam boat that went up and down
the Delaware but of course it was a
financial failure and nobody wanted to
support it for a second year and Fitch
was a disappointed man he the first
inventor well probably that there was
there was a Frenchman who had invented a
boat that that went went for a little
bit there was a man in Scotland who
invented there there were other
inventions and in fact probably
something on the order of 15 to 20 other
steamboats that had been tried before
Fulton's but he saw that it might be an
instrument for England and then he went
to France and tried to sell it there but
it wasn't it wasn't a passion with him
at all he he toyed with this invention
and that invention he kept on look
looking at things and borrowing other
people's ideas which which is what you
have to do actually when you're
inventing what book is this for you I
guess it's my ninth book I think so and
how did you get to interested in the
business of writing well that's all I do
how to do
when did you start it the book no more
write writing I can writing in college
and then after college where this was
the Cornell University I was the editor
of the stevie paper which was a daily
paper and I had to write a era toriel
page daily and it just seemed to be the
thing that I knew how to do and so after
college I went into newspapers magazines
and worked on the New York Times for a
while and then and I decided that I
really wanted to go off and write books
because when you're working at a
magazine the newspapers and people on
top of you telling you what to do and I
grew uncomfortable with that so now of
course there are always editors that
publishing houses and publishers who are
telling you what to do but they're but
they're they're kinder and gentler than
people in journalism what year did you
graduate from Cornell 58 the name
Kirkpatrick sale where does it come from
it's my little David by last name but
it's a Scottish English family and
what's your first name John and why did
you decide to drop John I never used job
at all ever
what did people call you to know you
well Kirk but I thought that Kirkpatrick
was a more elegant to have pen name and
and there are people who still call me
Kirkpatrick it's a question of intimacy
isn't it
where did you grow up in Ithaca New York
my father taught at Cornell and if you
know anything about it it's a beautiful
place in the summer and an intolerable
place in the winter and so as soon as I
could leave what I did how do you think
you got drawn into the writing thing you
have anybody that got you interested in
it first
oh my father is a professor of English
so I began reading writing I guess
that's how it happen
but it was largely the impulse to
journalism that and and writing everyday
that enabled me to hone the craft
sufficiently to to make a living at so
what year did you get interested in
Robert Fulton well that was no more than
about four years ago I have been
interested in doing something on the
Hudson for a long time but hitting on
the idea of Fulton was about four years
ago well I assured my publisher that I
would have them the manuscript you know
just a year or two years or something
like it with it but when you when you go
into this it always takes much longer
doing research than you ever anticipated
you point out in the book that mr.
Fulton at his grown age was about six
feet tall which is four inches taller
than the average person back then that's
right what do you think he would look
like you've ever here is this is this a
fairly good rendition of what he would
look like that's excellent rendition of
him and and don't forget to notice the
explosion in the background under the
fire of his genius because Benjamin West
who painted that picture and was a great
American painting in England a Court
painter actually four for the King was a
friend of Fulton's and that kind of
mentor of Fulton's and he knew that
Fulton had been spending his time trying
to sell his floating mines to the
British government and in the course of
that he blew up a ship a an old ship
without anybody on it in the harbor off
of the coast of England and West was so
impressed with with Fulton's account of
this that he included that ship blowing
up in the side of his picture but that's
exactly what he would look like a very
handsome man
and one believes that coming from
poverty as he did and with very little
schooling that it was his good looks and
the charm that he developed that really
got him his early successes total number
of years he lived in England so by I was
9 years in England in France and then
another six seven seven years in in
France and then he went to England and
then he came to the United States in
1860 and in that time he had he had
almost no success until the at the very
end when the British government paid him
a considerable amount of money ten
thousand pounds for his floating land
mines and his submarine and with that he
became a wealthy man that was a
considerable amount of money at the time
he died in 1815 you say at age 50 in his
lifetime did he marry he married he had
a partner in this business business who
was robert Livingston
who was one of the great American
Statesman who had been involved in the
writing the Declaration and the
Constitution he was a representative of
New York State
for much of that and he had been chiefly
responsible for getting Napoleon to sign
the treaty for the Louisiana Purchase is
that Bob Livingston the same one that
would have been related to the Bob
Livingston that almost became speaker
that's right my great great great
grandson but not not so clear a
relationship as that no but even they
were related right so is George Bush
actually another tenuous way but that
robert Livingston had the monopoly from
the New York State Legislature to run
boats on the Hudson River the operative
word there is Mahna Mahna right because
it plays a role in the whole book and so
he went to Fulton before they got
together in Paris and Fulton says I'll
build the boat and Livingston says well
I'll give you the monopoly and together
we'll be partners and actually they were
financial equals in this because by then
Fulton had enough money to to go in
fifty-fifty with Livingston and he built
the boat it was a success and Livingston
secured the monopoly and so nobody else
was allowed to run steamboats although
other people could could easily do so
I'm building a steamboat that worked was
not all that difficult Livingston was a
great patron of the Hudson Valley and it
was a cousin of his that Fulton met
during the course of his steamboat
ventures and Merrick and at what year
and in his life this is 18:8 just after
his success with the steamboat in 18/7
she's not a beautiful woman you would
have to say but she had apparently a
certain charm and she had spent some
years at a at a school so she had a
modicum of education but they didn't get
along they had a very sour marriage and
he treated her as as baggage you get
that sense treating his baggage that he
had to lug around make it
they had eventually three kids but he
wrote about the children as if they were
Harriet's his wife's responsibility her
property her baggage there's no warmth
at all for for his children there is a
letter of his in Paris when he's talking
about the first steam boat that he
created there and he refers to the steam
boat as his child and it's quite a warm
and wonderful description of how his
child is getting along and
we'll be able to move about in the world
he never wrote a comparable letter about
his real children ever his affection was
was them for his steamboat enough for
his children what was his relationship
with Joel and Ruth Barlow and who were
they uh well that's an interesting
question because we know something about
it but we don't know enough Joel Barlow
was then a famous American poet I would
written a poem about America in called
the Columbia and which was which was
revised he came out in eighteen seven
also
Joel was living in Paris he had gone
there in a land scheme that he stayed in
Paris and he had considerable amount of
money and Harriet was his wife and they
were happily married but they had a
habit of bringing other people men truth
I'm sorry Ruth Ruth that Barlow had a
habit of bringing people into their
relationship and one of the people they
brought in as soon as they met him was
Robert Fulton's this is in 1800 brought
Anna means what well they live together
the three of them a menage tois the
French gave the word to us it was a
threesome and they lived together for
those six years in Paris aids different
sufficient so that Barlow might have
looked upon Fulton as a son there was
there was a 20-year age difference there
and with her and with her but clearly it
was more than father/son there there was
clearly a sexual relationship among them
and we know most of this from letters
that Barlow wrote while Fulton and Ruth
were off on holidays
18 2 and 18 3 and it's they are
baby-talk letters full of sexual images
and there's clearly a sexual feeling
from Barlow to Fulton now we have no
evidence that this was returned Fulton's
letters do not survive from from that
period but Barlow is encouraging Fulton
to have a wonderful summer of sexual
pleasure with his wife and he says that
but he must not let himself his
beautiful body be deranged and if he
does anything wrong Barlow says he'll
come and cut off his penis he says this
in in the baby-talk fashion of his
letters their bizarre letters and it was
a bizarre arrangement for these three
but there was clearly real affection at
the bottom of it because when the Barlow
and Ruth finally go back to America and
settle down in Washington Fulton goes
there often just to see them and stay
with them and when he got married in
1880
then he took his wife down and he
thought maybe there could be a menage a
cot with the four of them in in
Washington now that was his hope and he
wrote us so much - - Barlow it didn't
happen his wife Harriet would have none
of it and and clearly was a disaster
is this well known in the history of
Robert Fulton or did you find this anew
it was it was known I think but not
talked about similarly I mean they don't
teach this to young kids in school no
they don't teach you that they yes they
teach him that he invented the steamboat
and then it was called the Clermont
neither is true we didn't invent it he
made the first successful steamboat run
but it wasn't called the Clermont it was
called in the North River
and they don't teach him about the rest
of this there's another incident here
too because while he was in England
Fulton stayed at the castle of the most
notorious homosexual in England powder
Ham castle down in Devon and he stayed
there for probably two years at least a
year to have somewhere along in that
line painting the portrait of the the
man who was was the Lord their Lord
Courtney but clearly living within that
venez as well now there's no suggestion
anywhere that there was a homosexual
relationship between the two of them but
it is known that the Lord Courtney
flaunted his homosexual life there and
he had parties and brought in people and
it was it was known it seems impossible
that Fulton could have escaped being a
part of that homosexual world and given
his looks and charm he might have been a
willing partner there and he needed that
because he had no other means of support
and if Lord Courtney was going to
support him that's fine on the back of
your book you have four people that
praise your book and one I want to read
a little bit of his Norman rush author
of whites and mating do you know mr.
rush yes who is he he's a novelist a
brilliant novelist who lives also in the
Hudson Valley
he says Kirkpatrick sail has decoupled
Robert Fulton from his steamboat and
yanked him out of the flattering dimness
of the pantheon of American inventors
revealing an altogether surprising
character and inspired self-taught
tinkerer who's greater genius lay in
exploiting the discoveries of others and
ethically hilarious monster of
self-promotion a failed merchant of
death a participant in a long-running
avant-garde domestic arrangement
who knew this essay in addition to
recasting the image of Fulton offers a
provocative reassessment of some of the
less noticed social consequences of his
greatest achievement and does both with
brevity Brio and style well thank you
for the rush you like her you know I
talked about Fulton to a school classes
of fifth graders the other day they're
about a hundred kids their fifth graders
and I told them about Fulton I told him
the truth about Fulton that I was gentle
on much of it but they had no trouble
getting it they could see who he was
they saw his brilliance and they saw the
fire and they saw how it had burned him
up why and do you think it deliberately
over the years that historians have you
know created an image about him it
wasn't accurate yeah I mean it's sort of
the parson Weems treatment of George
Washington and others that and we want
our heroes to be heroic and we don't
want them to have clay feet or we want
we want them to be perfect that's that's
very much part of American history
probably every nation's history tries to
do the same and so the the other parts
we don't even bother to examine now I
had some problem with this the question
of Fulton's homosexuality and it was
clear that that he was involved in these
these relationships but it's not clear
that it that had any particular effect
on his creativity on his inventiveness
on his work and and it's interesting
that he had a passion for Ruth Barlow
because that was the only passion for a
woman that he ever exhibited in his
entire life just that one and to an
older woman
so his marriage was as near as we can
tell entirely without passion and it
wasn't a mayor
of real convenience and power for poor
Fulton what do you think he would have
been like to know charming by all
accounts charlie everyone said that it
was he honest that's an interesting
question yes I think you could say that
he was honest within his own lights the
fact that he was traitorous in offering
his weapons of war all around to
countries other than his own I don't
think that's dishonesty exactly and he
didn't know he never saw it as traitors
and people actually said it to him
suggested to him that that it was he
wouldn't believe it
and you even Barlow was a bit upset by
by all of that but it but it never
touched Fulton what impact did having a
steamboat in this country especially up
around the Hudson and all have on the
future of the United States Wayne can he
compare with something that we have
today I mean you start out talking about
computers it was it as important as the
computer is today how did it change the
life of the United States well the
computer is such a Hydra headed a fair
that its difficulty to think of it as a
single invention but it had more impact
than any other invention until Colt
perfected his revolver in the 1840s it
was it was decisive in shaping the
course of American history in the first
half of the 19th century absolutely
decisive because not only could it work
on the Hudson but it worked on the
Mississippi River system that America
acquired in the Louisiana Purchase and
that transformed our country it made
America occupy the entire center of
the continent all the way to the Rockies
and create a huge economic machine in
that area bring in massive waves of
white settlers displacing Indians and
later the Mexicans and stamping American
culture and economics all over that huge
area and it became in fact more
important than the original 13 colonies
as a political and economic entity then
too in addition to allowing the
destruction of the native tribes and the
native flora and fauna it enabled cotton
to be a successful crop and therefore
slavery to exist to continue to exist
until then cotton was a a problematic
crop it it had some market in in England
and and some use domestically but it
wasn't significant and it is thought by
many historians that slavery was about
to go out of fashion as in in the know
in the south as it hadn't had in the
north there was still slavery both north
and south but it was it was diminishing
and then along comes this instrument
that enables you to carry big loads
cotton requires such an instrument big
loads up and down the rivers and and to
do it quickly and economically and so
the plantation economy was secured by
the steamboat and therefore King cotton
and therefore slavery right up into the
Civil War
what was his genius when it came to
actually building a steamboat well he
had a vision that of what it should do
and what it should should look like
which was in some ways flawed but it was
clear enough so that he was able to
build this first boat and have a success
with it
what's this photograph right and
and he was also enough of an artist to
be able to draw the inventions that he
wanted to create and those are drawings
from his patent for the steamboat that
he applied for an eighteen nine and he
was a skillful artist and he could
design the inventions that he wanted
built and he designed the steamboat with
great care and he carried out all all of
its building with great care he was
there in the shop he saw what his
workmen were doing he took care of every
detail inside the engine and outside
what's this
portrait right here that is
theoretically the North River on one of
its early journeys with the wind going
one way for the sails and the other way
for the smoke but nonetheless a fairly
accurate rendering of what the first
steamboat looked like and you say it was
not called the Clement was called a
North River it was called the North
River and that's all the only day how
did that name thing then get into the no
it's hard to say but in the first
biography written by a friend and his
lawyer caught Wallander Colin Holden
used that name we said it was called the
Clermont or the North River and that
somehow I don't know how he he got that
idea or he may have just been trying to
stay on the good side of the Livingston
family whose family home was called
Clermont but it was never called that in
on any paper or in any document or in
any letter that Fulton's wrote in New
York Fulton Street famous Street where
is it and why is it famous well it's an
honor that's that's rarely been accorded
to anybody
in New York he can name a street after
somebody but here they made a street and
it was a street that went between
Fulton's landings on the Hudson where
the steamboats the steam ferries went to
New Jersey and the other Fulton landing
on the East River where the steam
ferries went to Brooklyn and Queens and
they just plowed a road between those
two points after his death and named it
Fulton Street in his owner there's also
a Fulton Street in Brooklyn isn't there
a Fulton market also there was a Fulton
market that grew up at the foot of
Fulton Street on the East River though I
think that was called that rather more
for the street then for the for the
person go back again to the year that he
invented the steamboat er invented to
his steamboat 1870 and the country in
1870 the people the names that were ever
on everybody's lips at the in those days
who would that have been who are the
famous names and he didn't know them it
was Lewis and Clark Lewis and Clark were
the new heroes of America because it was
in an 18-6 that they came back from
their momentous journey to the Pacific
and there were celebrations of
Meriwether Lewis in in all the cities
around including Washington where there
was a huge banquet in his honor and to
that banquet went Barlow and his wife
and Fulton and Barlow and Fulton are
recorded as having given toasts which
was the then fashion to Louis for his
achievement and they probably also went
to Philadelphia where both of them were
have had work to do and they undoubtedly
met in Philadelphia as well and Lewis
was a kind of problematical hero because
shortly thereafter he took his own life
and that was not a good thing for a hero
do that's that that that tainted his
career but Fulton by that time was the
new hero because he had created this
successful steamboat and everyone could
see that that was going to be an
instrument of significance I don't think
anybody saw at the time how significant
I don't think anybody was thinking just
how important a instrument it was it
took America a few years to understand
that by nineteen seven the centenary
year Mark Twain who was on the committee
to celebrate this centenary and
celebrate Fulton said that Fulton and
the Mark Twain of course who had his
life on the Mississippi and do a lot
about the steamboat said that Fulton's
achievements have made the rivers useful
that before that they were just there
this was an instrument to made them
useful you also say in your book that
Chief Justice John Marshall who was the
longest serving chief justice something
like 34 years broke the monopoly yes
explain what the monopoly was how long
did it last and how did Chief Justice
Marshall break it
well the monopoly began in 1870 and was
renewed for four years even after
Fulton's death but it was challenged at
every point all the time and that took
Fulton to court into legislatures more
often than he wished to go who gave him
the monopoly this was from Livingston
this was the part of the deal he got he
persuaded the New York State Legislature
to do his bidding and he was a rich and
famous Patriot and they did his bidding
and they gave him the monopoly if he
could successfully provide a steamboat
he could have the monopoly on steamboat
travel on the Hudson how many boats did
Fulton build in his life well there were
12 13
and there were five of them that plied
the Hudson and then others were steam
ferries and then there was one boat boat
on Long Island and there were some of
the Mississippi eventually was this a
national monopoly that he had no and
that's why he was so late in going to
the Mississippi because he couldn't get
a monopoly of the Mississippi
he managed with the help of another
Livingston to get a monopoly on New
Orleans and from from New Orleans waters
and that sort of gave him a monopoly on
the Mississippi but it was effectively
ignored there were other people who were
putting boats on the Mississippi and
there was very little that that Fulton
could do about what was did the
legislature of New York have to grant
this monopoly to Livingston yes
was it a money thing I mean today was a
money exchange to get the monopoly no
this was the idea of that commerce would
be improved if we could get a steamboat
there and in order to get somebody to
invent it and put it out of the water
you had to give him the monopoly or else
they wouldn't they wouldn't do it so
what year was it broken
so after Fulton's death a lot of people
came trying to challenge it
Commodore Fulton was was one of them who
tried to challenge it and Commodore
phone
I mean Commodore of not Perry I mean I
see oh no the the man who later founded
the New York Central Railroad Vanderbilt
Vanderbilt
Commodore Vanderbilt was one of them who
began his career as a steamboat man and
he challenged the monopolies and others
did as well and then finally this went
into a state court and finally to the
Supreme Court in 1826 and it was then
that Marshall declared that this was
odious monopoly was odious and
and then declared that couldn't be any
in American waters but you say then
everything went crazy I mean thousands
of steamboats were created because the
monopolies well that that that helped to
expand the trade enormous Lee but it had
been successfully challenged on the
Hudson before that and successfully
challenged on the Mississippi in the
Ohio before that this was a league legal
assistance but people were gonna build
steamboats and use them no matter what
when when that monopoly was finally
destroyed though it it opens the
floodgates for the Hudson River although
by that time there were there were
hundreds of steamboats in the
Mississippi system and on other rivers
in America America needed the steamboat
it had these long rivers that were
otherwise as Mark Twain said useless not
quite but but but now they were useful
where's the best place in the United
States to find any kind of a monument to
Robert Fulton or a museum that has the
displays about him any place one one
place is Ron doubt New York there's a
museum that's devoted to Hudson River
maritime history but they that they are
they are sort of slamming on Fulton but
but they're very good on steamboats and
there is a group of people also on the
Hudson they're building a new monument
of no new replica of the original North
River where they will be in Saugerties
New York that's between well it's near
Kingston it's it's between New York City
and Albany and they plan for 2007 to
have this replica built and
on the Hudson River when you went about
writing this and researching it how did
you do that well there are there's lots
of correspondence particularly of Fulton
after eighteen seven some of it going
back into his English and French years
but but not not a lot but but
considerable records of that he kept on
the steamboat operations not enough it
wasn't it wasn't a meticulous year by
year account that that survives so you
have to correct a lot of guesswork where
is it it's in the New York Historical
Society and the New York Public Library
original letters original letters did
you see them over yes oh yeah what's the
handwriting
well it was it started out as a clumsy
handwriting with with bad spelling and
it developed into a very sophisticated
very very fluid handwriting and then
very very little bad spelling in it as
he became an educated and cultured man
your book is $24 it's 242 pages as these
books go today this would be a small
book did you do that on purpose
no oh I didn't think about that at all I
just wrote the story that had to be
written how many words did you have any
idea no and what I don't use a computer
so I don't know you do not I don't have
a word count on it how do you right
there on the typewriter
how long have you done that forever what
kind of a typewriter it's electric is it
always been electric know that that's a
concession about ten years ago and where
do you write in my home in Cold Spring
New York any time of day that you like
to do this more than others oh you get
up at 9:00 and you quit at 5:00 or
something like that it's a nine to six
job basically you do it every day and
are you already working on your next
book I am I'm trying to convince the
publishers of this Fulton book Free
Press to be interested in a book on a
somewhat larger theme of where did Homo
sapiens go wrong and I've located the
the time 40,000 years ago and I want to
write about the Stone Age and how Homo
erectus lived for 2 million years one
way and then Homo sapiens evolved and
taught us to live a different way what's
the difference between a hopeless homo
sapien and homo erectus the large
difference is an attitude toward nature
and it's it's astonishing you can find a
homo sapien how do you find a homo
erectus well that's easy that's skeletal
records provide that and we can tell
pretty much how the Homo erectus lived
without hunting probably without hunting
and certainly without hunting large
animals but Homo sapiens comes on and
developed Spears and spear throwers and
those after the large animals and
exterminates the large animals in a
wholly different attitude toward nature
that existed for the previous two
million years of human life and this
leads eventually to the domestication of
animals and domestication of plants
which we call agriculture and husbandry
and and that creates a whole new
attitude to nature and a whole new way
of distancing ourselves from nature so
that we can use it and I would say that
this is where we went wrong and that's
what I'm trying to to create a book
about at the moment
what was your best-selling book probably
the book Christopher Columbus that I
wrote that came out in time for the
Quinn centennial in 1992
and I had expected that Quinn Centennial
to be just a grand and glorious affair
on everybody's lips and on every
newspaper but it turned out that the
book my book which came out in 1990 got
people thinking that maybe Columbus
wasn't really all that great a fellow
and what he did was maybe really not all
that celebratory they say never really
landed in the United States of course
you didn't come United States no but he
did he did land in in the Americas and
he had an immediate and disastrous
effect and part of it was intended
he's enslavement and killing on all the
Indians part of it was unintended the
diseases that he brought over but it was
just animal mentis event and and it
changed the world forever but he himself
wasn't all that grand fellow and so the
bandwagon that I expected to be there in
1992 was somewhat derailed by by people
paying attention to what I was saying in
the years before that you'd to dedicate
this book for Delilah my American Dream
who is she and why is she your American
dream Delilah is my granddaughter three
and a half years old and she was born
while I was writing this book and she is
my American dream for the future
if anybody's gonna be able to survive
the very troublesome future that this
country and this species has before it
it will be somebody with the fire and
the joy of Delilah you said earlier you
written for a number of publication
including the New York Times when were
you it two times and for how many years
in the 60s for about three years more
where else have you written all across
the country every a lot lots of places I
at one time I was writing for lots of
popular magazines and then more recently
I have tried to narrow that down right
for the nation I'm a contributing editor
there what kind of things essays I guess
you would call them political political
not not so much journalism as essays on
contemporary here's define your politics
I am an anarchic communalist what does
that mean what it means is that I
believe in a small scale human scale
communities within confined natural
regions though these are called bio
regions where I come from but these
natural regions are where our efforts
should be confined and within them to
communities of a fairly small size so
that a human can have a real influence
on the events of one's daily life and
this is a dream that many people have
had this is called essentially
decentralization the decentralization
power the diffusion of power out of this
out of the centers down back to the
people at small community levels and I
am the secretary of the EF Schumacher
Society which is devoted to that same
vision that same dream
of trying to bring power and politics
and economies back to a smaller scale
who was the F Schumacher
yes Schumacher was an English economist
who wrote a book called small is
beautiful in the 18th in the 1970s and
it became a quite popular book putting
forth the notion of a smallest beautiful
decentralization alternative energy
alternative technologies and I think
still that this is the way we have to go
and I have gotten some encouragement
about this because I think it's
increasingly clear that nationalized
systems are fragile and in trouble and
that we had better bring power back down
to the people had a human scale if we
want to have a efficient and survivable
future we only have a couple minutes
left Robert Fulton had a not too
comfortable ending to his life age 50
1815 when he died you say there was this
facial boil that even closed an eye can
he what was that all about don't know
it's hard to say I mean he he had
several episodes of that kind of thing
he ended dying essentially of pneumonia
it was called various other kinds of
things at the time of that book that's
how we would think of it now
and he didn't take care of himself
fairly in short again that fire in his
soul was driving him to to achieve this
and that and more Fame and more fortune
yeah he had a restless soul that would
not even learn to take care of his own
health what did he leave his wife and
his kids well that's that's a question
it's it's not certain what he left there
is no will we don't know what is certain
is that 10 years after his death they
were destitute there's not certain
where that money went to probably his
widow had some of it and she married a
rather unscrupulous man who might have
taken it all for himself but what is
clear is that his family was destitute
within ten years after his death when
you finished your book did you end up
liking him so much that much resized
about that I think I would have been
overcome by his charm if I if I in fact
met him you know I had no idea at the
beginning that that he was quite the
scalawag that he was did he get the fame
that he wanted money he certainly got it
yes and and he is known to this day too
but every child in America I believe and
that is a considerable amount of Fame
and Fulton Street is still there plowing
through the middle of Manhattan this is
the cover of the book is called the fire
of his genius Robert Fulton as the
subject and our guest has been
kirkpatrick sale thank you very much
thank you I appreciate it